Conan O'Brien
everyone thank you for coming so far I'm
just going to assume you all came from a
really great distance who really came
from a great distance my apartment
building is attached to this
no your apartment building is attached
you should have a party for all of us
after the show we should all go back to
your apartment really I should invite
out the true stars of the show son OB
sessan and Mr Matt gorley let's get him
out
here I was warming up the crowd and it
turns out there might be a party
happening after the show all right
inches from where we're sitting right
now son and Matt okay yeah and Sona
likes to party let's welcome Ed
Sheeran well I sort of wanted to
normalize the word wank in America
because it's like not used that much so
hi my name is Ed Sheran and I feel wank
about being
on oh about being con o br's friend
people always say don't meet your Heroes
you mentioned don't meet your Heroes
that was shocking you came I'd made this
song Perfect that was uh starting to
pick up steam and become a hit and um
someone said oh we should uh put out
like a duet version of this and I was
like well realistically I don't really
want to do do a duet unless it's be want
say and they were like well why don't
you ask her and she said yes and it was
like it was I was so surprised I was
kind of rung her up on I was like do you
want to do it she's like yeah I'm in you
have a different life than I
do this special live episode of colel
Brian needs a friend is brought to you
by Samsung and the freestyle second gen
portable projector I've playing
Starfield through the freestyle second
gen it's on my wall which is 100 in and
it's so big I have to physically look
around for bad guys it's amazing yeah if
you think 100 in is big I
got what why why do I no
[Applause]
advertising
[Music]
no ass look at
this straight down
oh my
[Applause]
God